on Netflix is Wednesday the lead
character has a couple of boys clamoring
for her attention Jenna Ortega has some
thoughts about it and they're not what
you expect Jenna Ortega tackles the
iconic role of Wednesday Adams in
Wednesday a series that's broken
viewership records at Netflix while the
series pays homage to the characters
fans know and love from The Adams Family
but also includes new elements that add
to their backstory in this adaptation
Wednesday is a troubled teen headed for
Nevermore Academy Gomez and morticia's
alma mater that offers shelter to all
manner of monsters and outcasts
Wednesday is shown to be sardonic
quick-weighted and mischievous traits
that lead her to get wrapped up in a
mystery that threatens the lives of the
students at Nevermore even though she's
busy investigating Wednesday still has
time for a little romance after arriving
at her new school Wednesday quickly
finds two boys clamoring for her
attention there's a local teen named
Tyler The Helpful son of the town
sheriff and Xavier another Nevermore
student with strange Powers romance is a
common subplot in teen drama so it's not
all that surprising to see a love
triangle in the story however Ortega
isn't too fond of her character taking
part in such a cliche Trope throughout
season 1 of the series there's a monster
lurking in the woods surrounding
Nevermore Academy so naturally Wednesday
becomes determined to find out what's
going on the minds behind Wednesday
clearly wanted to keep the audience on
their toes because even as the boys try
to endear themselves to Wednesday it
becomes clear that either Tyler or
Xavier could be the culprit behind the
violent attacks that had been plaguing
the community however the love triangle
doesn't last by the end of the season
it's revealed that Tyler is the monster
effectively eliminating him as a
romantic interest or so it seems in any
case Jenna Ortega wasn't the biggest fan
of the storyline during an appearance on
the Canadian entertainment show e-talk
Ortega revealed that she wants to avoid
any more love triangles for Wednesday in
the future the actor explained well as
far as the boys went
I had to accept it Ortega then added
honestly I'm going to fight this love
triangle thing so hard because this is
just me being protective I don't think
Wednesday would ever be in a love
triangle even if you enjoyed Wednesday's
interactions with Tyler and Xavier
Ortega makes a good point there are
plenty of ways the series could develop
Wednesday's character without bringing
any Superfluous romance into the picture
in a Reddit thread criticizing
Wednesdays being nothing special one
Reddit user shared that like Ortega
they're not a fan of the season one love
triangle between Wednesday Tyler and
Xavier they wrote not every female
protagonist needs a love triangle or a
love interest for that matter I'm not an
anti-shipper or anything like that but
none of the love interest presented on
the show were likable or interesting to
me in response a number of commenters
either agreed outright or supported a
romance between Wednesday and her
roommate Enid as the only acceptable
option as the series continues even for
viewers who might have enjoyed
Wednesday's interactions with Tyler and
Xavier Ortega and her characters fans
all make a fair point there are plenty
of ways a series could develop
Wednesday's character without bringing
any superflu us romance into the picture
hopefully the writers take Ortega's
thoughts on love triangles into account
and lean into Wednesday's dark side if
the show gets a second season
[Music]